you're back on television you have this
new show are you enjoying it you
enjoying being back I love it I'm having
a lot of fun we you know when on Scrubs
we were just in abandon Hospital so I
thought you shot the whole thing in a
real Hospital but it was abandoned it
was an abandoned Hospital now we're on a
soundstage where it's freezing cold kind
of like this but even ten times more
cold we do this because Andy and I are
preserving our body yeah that's right
yeah we aged slower if we stay in this
well my nipples are actually fine here
but on go ass by the way
you're a very strange conversationalist
would you like some coffee no because
apples are fine it relates to my story
wouldn't say all my nipples oh okay over
there heard the term smuggling raisins
when your nipples it's like when your
nipples are out it's like ah sorry I'm
smuggling raisins right so first day of
Alex ink I get there and the set is
freezing and I'm wearing a thin shirt
and my nipples are rock hard and it's
like you know when it was Jennifer
Aniston on friends it's like cute
everyone wants to see that but they
don't want to see like no my rock-hard
nipples now so everyone's you know if
day one everyone's freaking out what are
we gonna do and they went and got me
pasties this rig they got paste used to
put over your nipples yeah they were
like we weren't planning to use these
for the men in the cast but we we do
have pasties for your rock-hard nipples
right so I put on pasties and also I was
wearing new underwear that supposedly
supposed to wick away moisture do you
know about this kind of underwear I
haven't heard about this okay so wick
away moisture yeah is that it wicks away
moisture if you're exercising and it
feels nice you know soft alright and but
but I was trying it out and what happens
is it if you if you have a little
dribble from a pea you know
[Applause]
once you're above a certain age yes you
shake shake shake shake shake shake
shake shake shake you're like this
you're like so we're giving yourself
quite a shake shake shake you kill the
bird anyway
shake shake shake right still gets a
dribble in the new wicking underwear
right wicks it right to the front of my
pants have a big pee stain it it's day
one of photography I got pee in my pants
I got rock-hard smuggling raises nipples
this is a disaster we heard my question
it's a design flaw with the underwear
why isn't wicking the moisture alter the
most visible area of the underwear hi
who did this crap Old Navy
all it does is not allow moisture to be
absorbed and that's great I guess if
you're jogging or right right but if
you're on set and you had a little yeah
you wanted to to go rid of it yeah so so
this was a freak show it sounds like a
woman had to have a hair dryer on my
peep area and I had that put area PC
pasties off my nipples it was day one a
photographer you still wearing pasties
right now okay all right
toss them Conan okay
you